okay so I'm going to talk to you now
about plutonium
so I once referred to uranium as the
booty man of the periodic table but if
you rhenium is sebou demand then there
is a hannibal lecter of the periodic
table and it's a couple of places to the
right and that element is plutonium
plutonium has a really quite nasty
reputation for example there's a book
here
plutonium history of the world's most
dangerous element when the human race
evolved evolved with uranium in the
environment so we physiologically can
actually deal with it to some extent
plutonium is a man-made element it
wasn't there in the environment when we
evolved and this means we've got
essentially zero tolerance to it so that
makes it quite dangerous for us we're at
Sellafield
in the northwest of England we're the
NLL central laboratory we're interested
in and plutonium because we need to be
able to recover it from spend reading
irradiated nuclear fuel you can't just
use plutonium in a regular laboratory
you have to have a laboratory which is
specifically designed to handle so it's
handled safely it's a at the point in
the periodic table were it does
interesting things there are not many
elements which you can say when they
were created you can sometimes say it
was discovered in 1869 or 19 whatever
but plutonium was made for the first
time in 1914 the reason that it was made
is that it's a radioactive element and
it decays away with a half-life that
depends on which particular isotope it
is if lutonium was created at some time
during the formation of the solar system
it has all decayed away long before
scientist ever started looking for it on
earth I have seen a lump of plutonium
once
I don't think I could tell you where I
actually saw it but it does just look
like a shiny piece of metal what we'll
see today is plutonium and solution now
that's really interesting because
plutonium has got some really intense
colors and the colors change depending
on the oxidation state of the plutonium
as well it's incredibly dense as a metal
you could take two with a hacksaw and
the hacksaw blade would break before you
chipped any plutonium off the sheer
density is shown by the fact that a
golf-ball sized lump of plutonium would
be over a kilogram easily really quite
heavy stuff so here the intention is to
recover the plutonium from spent nuclear
fuel
bouton is present in about 1% what we do
is use solvent extraction in order to
remove the plutonium from the fission
products in the aqueous phase and move
the plutonium up into a solvent phase
and that solvent phase is a mixture of
tributyl phosphate and a dill you in
cold
order order less kerosene here we have
some plutonium nitrate and then this
plutonium is in oxidation state 4 and
that's the oxidation state that's
extractable into tributyl phosphate I've
got two separate solutions here the both
plutonium nitrate they're just at
different concentrations it is dangerous
for several different reasons it is
dangerous because it is the basis of
atomic bombs the second atomic bomb
so-called fat man that was dropped on
Nagasaki in 1945 contained plutonium and
it was the plutonium that made it
explode it was a bigger bomb in terms of
the size of explosion than the first
bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima but
it's also dangerous plutonium because it
is very poisonous many heavy metals are
poisonous particularly say thallium but
plutonium is poisonous not just because
of its chemistry but because of its
radioactivity
plutonium decays radioactively by
emitting alpha particles helium nucleus
and when that hits the cells of your
body it can cause terrific damage and
that can lead to cancer and so on I'm
going to take some 30%
tbp but this is the solvent phase you
can see there it hasn't been mixed yet
this de solvent is less dense than the
aqueous phase and resides on top of the
of the aqueous but you'll see in a
minute that that brown color will go up
into the top phase according to this
book there is a club or there was a club
in Los Alamos the bomb factory where
they developed the chemistry of
plutonium and made the plutonium bone of
four people which had rather a strange
name this says you pee PU which means
your urine contains plutonium and these
are people who through some sort of
accident had plutonium in their body
there was one person that was described
called margul who was working with the
glovebox just like the ones that we saw
in the NLL labs and he had for some
reason a needle and he stopped the
needle through the finger of one of his
gloves and he pulled out his hand and
saw that there was a tiny black speck in
his hand which was a fragment of
plutonium and although the doctors
trying to dig this out for the next 50
years
plutonium could be detected in his urine
and it wasn't very high concentration
according to this he had to provide a
gallon of urine that's four liters
before they could detect the plutonium
but nevertheless he survived
okay so I've got two samples there with
plutonium nitrate at the bottom and
tributyl phosphate or - kerosene on the
top so what I'm going to do now is put
them into this device which is called a
vortex mixer so while that's that's
mixing plutonium's going up into the
solvent phase it will form an emotion
and the solvent and then start to
disengage from the aqueous phase and the
two phases all separate out plutonium is
formed in the nuclear fuel of nuclear
reactors uranium which has atomic number
92 can be transformed into plutonium
which has atomic number 94 by absorption
of neutrons so that uranium absorbs
neutrons that is the uranium-238 the
sort of uranium that does not
spontaneously fission and provide the
energy for the nuclear reactor the
Hanford Washington active material
production plant for uranium 238 the
most abundant isotope in natural uranium
is converted into a completely new
fissionable element known as plutonium
239 so it's the inner circle if you like
in active uranium isotope but that can
absorb neutrons and be transformed into
plutonium okay that should be I should
be done now
looks like an emulsion at the moment as
it separates you'll see that the top
phase has got now got the color in it
the plutonium nitrate has now formed a
chemical complex with tbp molecules and
those TVP molecules have made the
plutonium soluble in the organic phase
in the reprocessing irradiated nuclear
fuel all the fission products would now
be in this bottom phase and the
plutonium and uranium would be in this
top phase here
so you've separated them out plutonium
itself the metal is actually very
fascinating material I've never seen it
but it's meant to be very hard metal but
it has a surprisingly large number of
allotropes an allotrope is a different
crystal structure plutonium has six or
perhaps seven different allotropes which
differ in their hardness their
mechanical properties even their density
this makes the machining of plutonium
which is necessary for manufacture of
nuclear bombs extremely difficult
it also has quite a low melting point it
melts at six hundred and thirty nine
degrees centigrade which is really very
low melting point for a heavy metal for
example osmium which is not far away in
the periodic table has a melting point
well above three thousand degrees
centigrade some of the isotopes of
plutonium are so radioactive that
they're really quite hot so if you feel
the sample some of them can even be
glowing red hot but even the less
radioactive ones apparently feel quite
warm to touch though you have to be
quite brave to touch them what happens
in a solvent extraction process is that
the solvent is separated from the
aqueous phase and then new aqueous
liquor is added to that solvent to try
and recover the plutonium from it what
we're going to do is remove remove the
aqueous liquor from this now from the
bottom and replace it with some fresh
liquor that's got a chemical within it
that will promote recovery of the
plutonium from a solvent
taking the ACO space out out from the
bottom of course on an industrial scale
this is done with a variety of devices
why are you trying to get the plutonium
on its own because it has to be disposed
of in a special way or because you want
to reuse it it's separated and into a
pure form so they can be reused in
things like MOX fuel which stands for
mixed oxide fuels so that's where you
combine plutonium with uranium and you
can put it back into nuclear reactors
and generate new energy there is also an
interesting feature that when they decay
radioactively they give off these nuclei
of helium atoms so as you get an older
and older sample of plutonium the helium
builds up in this crystal structure so
although it looks like a piece of metal
in fact it has helium atoms inside it
rather like the fruit inside the cake
and because of this crystal structure
you tend to have crystallites with
boundaries so-called grain boundaries
between the crystallites and the helium
can accumulate on the grain boundaries
and weaken the metal quite substantially
the helium has two problems obviously in
the short term if you are somebody who
makes bombs you have to be careful that
you don't build that too much helium in
your the core of your bomb because it
then may not perform properly here in
sequence are the four snapper blasts
detonated atop a steel towers on the 7th
and 25th of May
and the first and per from Joule certain
problem is that if you were storing
plutonium which has come from
reprocessed nuclear fuel and is just
being stored at waste until it's safe to
be in the environment you will bury it
somewhere in the ground in a very strong
container and when you're designing that
container you have to allow from the
fact that your metal will start
producing a gas as it decays and
therefore your container has to be able
to withstand the internal pressure so it
doesn't suddenly explode which would be
embarrassing if not for you for your
grandchildren or their grandchildren
when they suddenly discover that these
secure containers have blown up did you
did you just describe the explosion of a
container containing radioactive
plutonium waste as embarrassing yes you
were right for all the excitement about
plutonium it all looks pretty harmless
they had a little that muddy brown
solution well it's a highly radio toxic
and you won't want to drink that either
well I won't you know that looks a
little bit like coke in order to get
that plutonium back into the aqueous
phase I'm going to use two different
techniques one is a reduction to get
plutonium for into a plutonium 3
oxidation state so what I'm going to do
to this one is add a chemical called
hydroxyl amine nitrate this is a another
method we use in a complex until
molecular compound and the chemical that
we're using is called acetyl hydroxamic
acid when we've mixed it all the
plutonium will be in the bottom
okay so this is the acetyl hydroxamic
acid solution and it's just disengaging
now between the aqueous and the organic
phase and as you can see the color in
the top phase is completely gone now so
that's the solvent solvent is now free
of plutonium and it's come back into the
aqueous phase and that aqueous phase can
then be sent to downstream plants for
final purification and conversion into
the final form which is plutonium
dioxide so this doesn't mean quite as
effective but you can see there the
alien's color that was in there there's
in the top half as and has been diluted
now and most of the plutonium is in the
in the bottom half as plutonium 3 so I
have another story I've told it before
but it's really good and Brady wants to
hear it again one of the people who
taught me chemistry a professor at
Cambridge Alpha Mandic worked on
plutonium during the Second World War
and one night when he was really quite
tired he spilt the entire United Kingdom
supply of plutonium which was ten
milligrams onto the table the bench that
he was working on he was really upset
he'd lost the whole country's supply so
he got a saw and cut a hole in the top
of the table he burnt the wood and from
the ashes of the wood he got back nine
and a half milligrams of the ten
milligrams he'd lost and he would have
hidden the whole thing that he was so
tired by then that he didn't have the
energy to repair the table top so when
people came in the next morning there
was a big hole and so they discovered
what's happened so the one on the left
here with the red solution is an
plutonium for with hydroxy tor
hydroxamic acid on the right here it's
platonic the blue
tony i'm at the bottom is plutonium
three that's been reduced by
hydroxylamine nitrate